One year ago an attempted coup in Turkey
failed. It's still not clear exactly what
happened. Who was behind it?
President Erdogan blames Fethullah
Gulen: a US-based Islamic cleric and an
ally turned critic. But the evidence
Erdogan has offered in support of his
extradition has been short on proof.
There's other suspects: officers upset by
Erdogan's anti-secularist leanings had motive.
Erdogan himself once quipped: "my goal
is to raise an islamic generation," or it
could have been a Reichstag fire type
plot to justify a crackdown.
Erdogan called the attempt a "gift from God."
My own theory is: all of the above.
Erdogan may have discovered the plot
early, but allowed it to continue to
justify the crackdown.  What's certain is
is this: Turkey today is a dictatorship. It's
anti US,
anti Europe, and pro Russia. It's the
most anti NATO NATO member. What we're
witnessing now however is a sprint to
erase Ataturk's legacy and replace
Turkey with an Islamic state by 2023 the
hundredth anniversary of turkey's
independence we've been covering turkey
a lot of AEI check out our work at WWII
org or let us know your thoughts in the
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars cover in
60 seconds and be sure to subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI